there is sort of an eerie parallel
and you have to be extremely careful
drawing such parallels and such
um
connections to this
uh unexplainable
war in uh that is world war ii
but
is there elements
of this that do echo in the actions of
vladimir putin
and
more specifically
do you think the vladimir putin is a war
criminal
can that label be assigned to the
actions of this man
so war criminal is a legal determination
and it requires evidence and due process
and the ability to defend oneself
we don't just decide
in the twitter sphere
or on a podcast that somebody is a war
criminal
they can be a suspected war criminal
and we can gather evidence to try to
prosecute that case and then the issue
for us lex is which court does it go to
what's the appropriate place
does it happen in ukraine because
they're the victims does it happen in
the hog because there's an international
criminal court there
does it happen inside russia because
there's regime change at some point and
some of these people
become
let's say they get arrested by their own
people inside russia
so those are all important questions
that have to be pursued with resources
and with determination and
and by skilled people who are
excellent at gathering that evidence and
that process is underway and ukraine has
a trial underway now
of one
alleged war criminal
who's pleaded guilty and and we'll see
what the
outcome of that trial inside ukraine is
of a lower level official not obviously
vladimir putin but the commander of a
tank group
so
yes
the names are eerily familiar
izum
harkief
kiev
right those are the names we know
from the nazi invasion and the nazi
occupation
of ukraine
and it's
very deeply troubling to think that this
could happen again
and there's a bizarre sense
that the russians
claiming as putin says to de-nazify
ukraine
have invaded the same places that the
nazis invaded
back in 1941 as somebody who's working
on volume three
of
your work on stalin going through this
period
is it eerie to you yes it is lex that
you're
i've written the chapters of volume
three i've drafted the chapters on the
war
and and as i said the place names are
very evocative unfortunately
but but you know
the nazis failed ultimately
they
captured ukraine
for a time
but they were evicted from ukraine
there was massive
partisan or guerrilla warfare resistance
behind nazi lines the whole time
that they were
allegedly in control of ukraine
if you look at the maps on cable tv they
show you the sign of russia they show
you the coloring russian control and
they draw a line and then it's colored
in
but the word control is misplaced
they don't actually control it it's
russian claimed or
or extent of farthest russian
troop advancement
because behind the russian lines in
ukraine crimea accepted
you have insurgencies you have the armed
insurgency in militopol for example
which is a place that you know
in southeastern ukraine
there is a guerrilla war now underway
to
hurt the russians who are in occupation
of that city and region
and we're going to see that continue
even if
the war becomes a stalemate
even if it stalemates more or less at
the lines we're at now
which would mean
that
anticipated ukrainian counter-offensive
at scale proves unsuccessful
the russian army doesn't disintegrate
and you end up with
a stalemate where there could be a
ceasefire not a cease-fire but neither
side is attempting an offensive for the
time being
there will be resistance behind those
russian lines and it will be fierce
resistance
the kind of resistance we saw to the
nazi occupation
ultimately it took
the red army
reinvading
the territory of ukraine and succeeding
at combined opera arms operations at
scale a massive counter-offensive much
larger than anything we're talking about
today
ultimately required that to evict the
nazis from ukraine
but in the meantime they did not have an
easy occupation regime there
uh ukrainian partisans
soviet partisans
killed
nazi officials vermont soldiers vermont
officers blew up
the infrastructure they were using
made them pay a price for their
occupation
we could well see
if unfortunately this ends in a
stalemate for the time being
we could well see that type of
insurgency gain momentum behind russian
lines
and and try to evict the russians that
way
and then remount the counter offense of
its scale later on in the future
if the first one doesn't succeed
so that would be further
echoes
of the world war ii experience the scale
once again is much smaller
the size of the armies here
they're not in the
many hundreds 800
700 000 a million two a million four
that's not what we're talking about
today
but the weapons
the cruise missiles
right
artillery fire
you know artillery fire used to be very
inaccurate and it was like saturation
you were just fired towards the enemy
lines and if you hit something you hit
something and if you didn't you just
kept firing
now you have drones lex
and so artillery fire is now sniper fire
because you can coordinate the direction
of the artillery fire with the drones
the drones can take a picture and show
you where the enemy is precisely located
and you can align that artillery to hit
them instead of just indiscriminately
bombing an area a territory
and the nato supplied artillery goes
really far
and you can fire into russian positions
and yourself not be exposed to russian
fire because your
artillery
fires farther than theirs
so that's coming
and we're going to see that in action
and so
the scale is not the same but the
weapons the precision of some of the
weapons and some of the nato we're not
sending all of our stuff
but as i said the dynamic is russia
commits atrocities russia bombs schools
russia bombs hospitals russia kills
civilians
and more
and heavier and more lethal
western weapons go to ukraine their
willingness to risk their lives
is really so impressive and the reason
that we it's
it's our duty
we're obliged to supply those weapons
and so the russians don't have that
resupply and the ukrainians do
and so the russians are now digging in
lex they're digging in deeply in the
areas that they've penetrated
and they're trying to build unassailable
positions
when for when the ukrainians transition
from mostly defense to full-scale
offense
and we'll see if that now i mean they're
digging everywhere
you know as they say
kapayut compiled right they're digging
everywhere behind your russian is
beautiful digging in i wish likes like
yours
but so so there are these things that we
can't predict but there are these things
we're watching and watching closely
and on top of that something that's not
in world war ii or for the most part is
cyber attacks and cyber warfare which
is uh
much less perhaps
um
convertible into human words because it
happens so quickly it's just large
scales so difficult to trace and all
those kinds of things it's not bullets
it's
uh electrical signals and that's yeah
but those ukrainian people they're like
eulex
they're young
and they're technically really
proficient yeah and they've been amazing
you know they spent those teenage years
in the basement yeah playing video games
not turns out it's useful after all it
turns out it's more than useful you can
save your country that way
and so they're not alone they're getting
support
and that support is important
but really predominantly it's ukrainians
on the cyber battlefield
and their skills have been very
impressive and they've been preparing
for this for a number of years
and they have a whole army of young
people
on the cyber side
it's their civilian population these are
not people conscripted into the military
or volunteering
wearing the uniform
and so even in cyber warfare the
ukrainians have been extremely
impressive
and so let's remember
that all of these aspects
of warfare
whether it's
how far your cruise missiles go and how
accurate they are
what size your cyber capabilities are
and it's really ultimately about the
people it's about the human capital
right it's it's about
the their willingness
their skill level but also their
willingness to fight and to put their
lives on the line
and there's no substitute for that and
so what's called morale
or courage or bravery or valor
that's really the ultimately decisive
provided you have enough sufficient arms
right to conduct the fight and if you
don't you use a molotov cocktail
right grandma calls in the coordinates
of the russian tank
on her iphone
and you
have a molotov cocktail that
the the people who used to work in the
cafeteria
are now stuffing flammable liquid into
bottles and you carry one right up to
the tank and you smash it against the
tank or you drop it in
one of the hatches in the tank right
there's no substitute for that kind of
stuff that that level of resolve
willingness to die for your country
that's a really big lesson
that we need to absorb in our own
country
we've been going to war
more frequently than we should
and like you said without the
justification all the time and then like
henry kissinger said without
understanding how this was going to end
it's easy to start a war it's very
difficult to win a war prevail in a war
or end a war on terms that that meet
your original expectations right
we've been fighting wars but we haven't
been fighting wars as as societies
we've been fighting wars as a small
sliver of our population
something like one percent of our
population is involved with the military
because we have an all-volunteer force
and that means that it's easier for our
politicians to go to war
because they don't face
conscription
they don't fade they don't have the
draft which affects every family in the
country
and because
the number of people in the volunteer
force is such a narrow
stratum of the population and so they've
been getting away with this
because the professional army is much
better than the conscript army and in
all volunteer forces much preferable
from a military point of view
but from a societal point of view
it enables you to go to war too easily
as a politician
and it doesn't engage the society the
same way that the ukrainian society is
completely engaged
from those young hackers all the way up
to those grandmothers
you